right so this question what's the
derivative of log X we are going to
prove this in a similar way to how we
proved it with e to the X but this one
is much quicker which is a relief so
you're going to like don't blink or
you'll miss it okay it's like three
lines may be coming in a cryptic okay so
as so often happens what we'll do is
we'll start with some existing knowledge
and then we will move to the part that
we want right so if I said y equals e to
the X then I know the derivative of this
is just e to the X that's simple right
so far so good
okay how about learn do something a
little bit weird here I'm going to take
this guy and one of the reasons why we
write it as a fraction is to remind you
of the fact that it came from rise over
run and it really is in almost all the
context of context you're interested in
you can treat it just like a normal
fraction like you know in chain rule
like things cancel right so I'm going to
do something to this that I do with
normal fractions which is I'm going to
take the reciprocal now why would I do
this I just want you to think for a
moment remember we talked about the fact
that Exponential's and logs are just the
same object looked at from different
points of view okay now I want you to
compare this derivative with this
derivative what does this mean this is
rise over run
yeah changing why compared to change in
X so let's just do y over DX you're
differentiating Y with respect to X
that's what that means okay now have a
look at this because this is not just
any fraction this is a special like
there's limits and all that kind of
weird stuff baked into this right this
doesn't just mean the reciprocal of what
you started with this means you are
differentiating X with respect to Y do
you see that like it's asking a whole
different question
from the other angle just like we're
trying to think about with Exponential's
and Long's
okay because this thing is a derivative
with respect to Y it's a little bit
weird to write the right-hand side with
respect to X like
it's meant to be with respect to why
thankfully I can write the right-hand
side in terms of why really easily think
back to when you were doing volumes you
had to change back and forth between x
and y have a look at the board there's
not that much written here to help you
what else could you say what is e to the
X in this context it's just Y like
that's literally the first thing I wrote
down right so it's 1 over Y is that ok
so if y equals e to the X that's what I
started with I get to this I get to that
hmm the part of your brain that I'm
trying to flex right now is the part
that looks at an object and is able to
change perspective on it okay this is
quite hard so I'm going to give you a
bit more of a nudge in the right
direction this object here I can look at
it from the opposite perspective by
translating it from an exponential into
a log right same equation we just looked
at from the other way so how would I
rewrite this if it wasn't an exponential
but a log function what would become the
subject of the equation have a look
what's operating here the subject is
currently Y right if I look at it from
the opposite perspective the subject
should become X isn't that right like
I'm doing the same thing over here then
I'm trying to switch around right what's
X going to be equal to well it's going
to be a log base E which I have a lazier
quicker way to write ok and that's why
this is going to be where Y appears this
is the switch in perspective okay so if
y equals e to the X this weird thing is
what I get but y equals e to the X and x
equals log of Y are the same thing these
are one objects right so therefore the
same derivative statement should be true
for both is that ok all right now
remember I told you blink and you'll
miss it have a look at this we're gonna
do the final switcheroo to really change
perspective ok X's and Y's X's and Y's
I'm going to swap everything every X I'm
going to replace with
and every why I'm gonna replace with an
X okay they're just labels right I mean
if I wanted to I could change them for
use or I could change them for teas or I
could change them for Eric so it's just
a label okay so let's do this on the
left hand side I'm going to get instead
of X log Y I'm gonna y equals log X is
that okay
swaps done maybe deal have a look at the
right hand side what am I going to get
instead for this derivative it won't be
DX and dy it'll be do Y on DX and the
right hand side will just be one a next
hey presto done that's the derivative
okay so just like with Exponential's
where the derivative is really nice and
simple the derivative those logs are
also nice and simple and this is really
cool because it solves some mysteries
for us a mystery which I don't know how
many of you spotted before we've got a
derivative statement here gives us an
integral statement let's take this
derivative statement and get an integral
statement out of it what integral am I
going to write the integral of 1 over X
the thing that I ended up with with
respect to X should send me back to
where I began right which is log X with
of course one difference namely it's off
by a constant because it could be any of
those right ok now just look at this
left-hand side look at this left-hand
side 1 over X this this is like
something you've seen before you've seen
lots of integrals that look like this
and you would instinctively rewrite it
not as a fraction but as something with
an index right because we're good at
dealing with indices with integration
right so this is X to the power of
negative 1 now this is the same thing
this hasn't changed now
do you remember we learnt a rule for
dealing with integrating things to a
power right X to the power you would say
the integral of X to the N is what what
are we we're so good at this now what do
we do to the power we add 1 and then we
divide by our new power and then don't
forget the constant right now your
exercises should have very carefully
dodged if I did a good job
this kind of question because look at
what happens when you apply this rule to
this what happens to the power
it becomes zero and then you're supposed
to divide by that new power and you're
like oh I broke Matt's okay well the
reason why that rule doesn't apply here
is because it's a whole different object
that you're supposed to land on right so
that's why we just kind of artfully
avoided that because we have we were
waiting until now okay